if you died came back to life and now
you're forced to hunt aliens in a real
life death game what would you do i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to be the
aliens in ghance kay is your typical
high school student and he's going to
die he's self-centered as hell and has
embarrassingly high levels of
testosterone he goes through the usual
hum and drum life of school and on the
way home decides to take the metro but
that was his biggest mistake and one
that will cost him dearly at the metro
he meets this old fossil of a lady who
asks for directions just as he sees his
old classmate selfless kato suddenly
this drunken fool falls down onto the
track and nobody tries to help him kay
has no interest but kato rushes to save
him and struggles to lift him off of the
track just as he spots kaye he drags
kaye down onto the track through some
good old-fashioned high school
awkwardness the boys then managed to
help the homeless man but now the train
is barreling down towards them and they
can't get back up so they start to run
okay this is absolutely horrifying kanto
may have played the hero card without
thinking but it's exactly this kind of
recklessness that is going to cost him
big the two boys are lucky that they
both had the strength to carry that bum
over the platform but that was risky
like the same reason why they advise
adults to put on oxygen masks first
before putting it on their child in an
airplane you can't help someone if you
can't help yourself first it's noted
that trains have an average speed of
between 125 to 200 miles per hour with
the latter end of the spectrum being
more commonly found within the trains in
japan however like all trains a decrease
in speed is needed before a full stop at
a station this is why it is safe to
assume that kato or k could have instead
ran towards the tunnel where the train
was coming from and get the attention of
the operator sooner as the train would
have already been in a gradual state of
decreasing in speed meaning there was a
higher chance for the train to stop
earlier before it ran over that bum on
the track this was the most obvious
method of saving that fool trying to
outrun the train by running to the
opposite end of the tunnel was really
their only option once they were on the
tracks despite how movies make it seem
because
movie magic ducking onto a train while
theoretically possible is extremely
unlikely and one that would likely lead
to a gruesome death i'd say that bum had
a good life and if it wasn't good then
will hey sucks to be him all the more
reason to die an early death the two
boys run for their life begging to be
spared but mother nature is one cruel
mistress as the train catches up to them
and kills them it decapitates them right
then and there with their lifeless heads
plopping right into the rows of
horrified passengers who witnessed the
gruesome event suddenly can kato end up
in a strange apartment room no pain no
nothing as their bodies are completely
normal something seriously freaky is
going on as they notice more people
already in the room staring back at them
and right in the middle of the room
stands a ginormous black sphere and it
sits there menacingly across from them
little do they know that this black
sphere will change their lives forever
kay demands to know what's going on and
asks around the mysterious room if
anyone has any idea and to add to the
scariness they look out the window to
see tokyo tower but can't for the life
of them open the balcony doors it's
almost as if they're ghosts this scares
the hell out of them as they try to
scream and find out just what the hell
is going on but unfortunately for them
no one can hear them scream nor can they
call for help as their phones don't work
they're trapped in this room and no one
is coming to save them they then find
out from the silent crowd who look back
at amusement at the two boys that
everybody here is here for a reason and
that they all came here after dying
horrible deaths dying and reappearing in
this very room in various ways with no
memory of how they got there k then
freaks out against mad at kato whose
goody two-shoes niceness got them both
killed okay if i was suddenly in a room
after being at a train station seconds
earlier this would have obviously meant
that something was up we have no idea
what's going on we could have observed
by everyone telling us that everyone
came here after dying which means that
this is likely what just happened to us
even if this fact feels like something
out of a science fiction novel now i'm
no astrophysicist but it's safe to say
that what just happened isn't part of
what we know about the universe in
general we're experiencing something
alien-like that's happening to us
especially if we can't touch or interact
with the windows or balcony doors and
knowing where we just came from for
example lying dead under the tracks this
makes me suspect that either we're in
heaven hell or some form of purgatory
and we're probably in for something far
more sinister our only move here is to
gather as much valuable information that
we can from everyone here i get everyone
to start yapping away so i can find out
enough details and hopefully find some
correlations between their stories
because as much as i hate it no one can
hear our screams meaning these strangers
are our best bet in staying alive or
whatever the hell we are at this moment
all of a sudden a new member pops up in
the room with everybody else appearing
through a laser projection slowly coming
into existence from thin air this naked
redhead girl then plops down into k's
lap as he gets excited and horrified but
mostly excited as people around him
think he's a full-blown creep i would
agree with them but this group isn't
playing around as this yakuza member
grabs her unconscious naked body and
drags her into the hallway for some
happy time everybody is scared shitless
and no one bats an eye forcing kato to
play the hero card yet again and go save
her but he doesn't realize that this
hero complex will cost him his life very
soon kato then gets in between the
yakuza man and red-haired girl as he
tries to choke him then all of a sudden
a horrifying sound rings out throughout
the whole room interrupting everyone and
summoning them back into the other room
it's the black sphere a message then is
displayed on the screen saying your
lives are now over what you do with your
new lives is for me to decide this
creepy-haired kid then says that the
black sphere's name is gantz and
mentions that no one is getting out
alive gantz then writes another message
on the screen showing a type of monster
with its traits and abilities shown for
all to see implying that this is some
kind of a terrifying game gants suddenly
opens up revealing an arsenal of
high-tech weapons designed to kill and
also reveals a strange man inside the
gantt's machine kay then finds a case
with his name on it as the others do the
same inside he discovers a black
futuristic suit as he sees creepy-haired
kid already putting on his it's almost
as if he knows something we don't all of
a sudden the crowd is then transported
one by one out of the room and into a
mysterious street as kay rushes to put
on his suit before disappearing they
then see a train track and decide to go
to see which station they are near
creepy-haired kid then explains the most
insane thing ever and claims that aliens
exist on earth and gance has tasked them
with capturing them and for each alien
you kill you get 10 million yen he shows
them his location device revealing to
the group the location of an alien and
he sets off it's show time boys and
whatever the hell that means all i know
is that [ __ ] is about to go down which
means i need to leverage my odds in
order to stay alive because what this
creepy-haired guy told me is whatever
we're up against probably won't be a
walk in the park the room had suitcases
with suits made specifically for us with
our own names on it gantz whatever the
hell that means was prepared for us to
come here and right now we're at a
disadvantage since we lack the context
or information to know what's really
going on like a very very bad game of
dodgeball we'll have a better chance if
we pick the winning team to go with and
right now that team consists of just
creepy-haired guy he knows what's going
on and even had the foresight to put on
his suit earlier before anyone else did
which means he's either prepared or
knows something that we don't and at
this point that's good enough for me so
i'm going to charm the skinny jeans
right out of this guy and make him my
friend because i want to live now
there's a chance he may screw me over
since demonstrations in his character
tell me that he's kind of a dick so i'd
bring kato and k with me to stick with
him throughout along with the red-haired
girl at the off chance he screws me well
then that's what the red herd girl is
for she'll make for a killer distraction
the group cautiously sets off but this
old man decides he's had enough [ __ ]
for today and decides to head home but
once he leaves a crazy lightning beam
from the sky shoots down and right into
the old man's head causing it to explode
expelling his brains and human pieces
all over the street no one leaves until
gatz says so elsewhere this glasses guy
finds the green alien chilling in an
apartment as he comes out and says green
onions are enough for me the gang is
confused as all hell but isn't wasting
no time they don't realize it yet but if
they don't finish the objective in time
they will all die the gang tries to kill
the alien but the gun doesn't work and
the alien sets off in fright evading the
group as he backflips off the ledge and
lands on his head spewing his brains on
the pavement just as k and kato show up
but this green alien is tough as hell as
he gets up and runs off with the gang
running after him passing by other
normal people who are not suited up and
who cannot see k or kato or anyone it's
almost as if they are in the afterlife
kato demands answers as he falls the
group as they corner the green alien
just as this blonde hair guy shoots but
misses the alien but this alien's time
is finished and the gang wants blood
they finally shoot him at point-blank
range as parts of his body get blown off
one by one kato freaks out and begs them
not to kill the alien but it's too late
just then they hear a girl across the
balcony who yells for her mom clearly
not seeing any of the gantz members
right in front of her suddenly this
blonde guy's face changes dramatically
his mouth begins to whimper and his eyes
bulge out from his head as we find out
that he's just been stabbed and behind
him we see a big green alien towering
over them this alien is much bigger and
is thirsty for blood i would like to
point out that this is not the time to
mess around we gotta get our act
together this gang was given a short
list of the aliens traits including its
traits and behaviors which means they
likely would have had an easier time
dealing with this adult version of this
alien if we just dealt with the child
alien a little more discreetly as it's
obvious that the adult version of this
alien grew much more angry once it saw
its child brutally massacred kanekato
have the weaponry to deal with him but
at close range this alien has
retractable claws making shorter range
encounters more deadly than one would
realize i would have first dealt with
this by shooting a center mass such as
the chest or stomach if they know what's
good for them they would try and shoot
off his limbs as soon as possible as
this will [ __ ] arguably its most
powerful offense and then after will
make him a lot easier to capture or kill
the big green alien then grabs this
yakuza guy by the head and traps him
piercing his skull with his razor sharp
claws glasses guy then fires his gun but
shoots the yakuza guy instead causing
him to explode littering his organs all
over the floor they now have only 30
minutes left everybody freaks out as the
green alien monster cuts glasses guy's
arms off and kills greysuit guy bodies
begin to pile up as graysuit guy gets
back up a final time as he fires his
pistol the green alien then confronts
kato as he tries to reason with the
monster because he doesn't want to kill
anybody the green monster then lunges
for his throat as kato dodges his
attacks but falls off the road k then
takes red herd gold because that's so
typical of him and runs for their lives
but suddenly the green alien is hit by a
car but the driver can't see who they
hit nor can they help k and red haired
girl ignore their terrible fate they
need to run now the green alien is
harder to kill than the terminator and
he gets back up and chases the duo k
then distracts the green alien and lures
him away from redhead girl k running at
a full sprint and jumps with all his
might off of a ledge with his suit
somehow propelling him higher into the
sky than is humanly possible landing
without taking any fall damage looks
like this suit has some powers okay this
was stupid on their end we've just found
some invaluable evidence that while
people can't see us we can still
interact with everyday objects making us
different than that of ghosts they
literally had the perfect chance to
steal that car from these unsuspecting
people and could have gained the upper
hand by having a car from here they
obviously could have run him over again
and again and again until that freaking
little [ __ ] is dead or for a more
effective method they could have
conducted drive-bys at close range
without taking any damage or being at
the mercy of these green aliens chasing
speed as it looks like he's pretty much
as fast as us on foot but not by car
humans are so stupid the green alien
then meatball rolls down the stairs and
tries to kill k just as kato appears
back from the dead and arm bars the [ __ ]
out of him which was so freaking awesome
before k makes his suit give him super
strength and beats the hell out of the
alien subduing him then someone out of
nowhere fires a special gun and traps
the alien it's creepy-haired kid and it
appears that his suit has the ability to
make him invisible creepy-haired kid
gives kay the final honors to kill the
green alien but he can't do it so
creepy-haired kid kills the alien once
and for all but their horrifying journey
isn't over not even close and looks like
someone is badly injured it's kato the
gang realizes that he's critically
injured and on the verge of dying
creepy-haired kid says that if he
doesn't stay alive till the end of the
game then he dies for good but if he can
stay alive till the end of the timer
that the game will reset killing him
good is new but is not looking too good
for him and just then everybody starts
teleporting back to gantz much to the
dismay of k and red haired girl who
curse the heavens as they try to wake up
kato but fail back at the room the gang
sits in defeat just as kato somehow
magically teleports back he's alive gans
then gives everyone their scores
providing zeroes all around except for
creepy-haired kid k and kato demand to
know more about this world as
creepy-haired kid spills the beans and
tells them that he's been here for over
a year and how if people die in this
game gantz then collects more people
from the outside world to play
creepy-haired kid then says they can all
go back to their lives resulting in
everyone happily leaving the gants room
to wait for the next death game okay so
we need to start studying on this [ __ ]
as soon as possible this includes
learning about things imperative to our
survival in a variety of situations as
who knows in this death game and where
it takes place we know one thing for
sure and that is no matter how much
damage i take in the game if i can make
it back alive even barely alive then
gantz will make me good as new this
means that i need to learn how to stay
alive long enough until the game ends
the mandatory killing alien part aside i
think we have a shot at surviving this
if we start now this includes learning a
little bit more about survival tactics
and military tactics since our group is
basically our own team of soldiers for
example learning to attack from a
defensive position feigning a retreat
focusing more on skirmish tactics if
such a thing is even possible against
these alien bastards once the crew
leaves the ghance building their lives
go back to normal including not being
invisible to everybody in the world as
if it were all a dream but red-haired
girl wishes it were a dream as she heads
back home to some devastating news turns
out she didn't kill herself and is now
in the hospital recovering from her
attempted suicide which means this
red-haired girl is now a copy of herself
looks like gance made a mistake and one
that will now cost her badly later kaye
wakes up and finds out sadly that him
now being an alien monster hunter was
not a dream and gets ready for school
knowing what we know that it's only a
matter of time until he summoned to play
again the school routine then goes back
into full swing as kay and everyone else
go back to their regular classes and
regular problems glasses guy complains
to kaye about his bully problems but
then this bully shows up demanding
glasses guy to pay up but says that he
can transfer his debt to k if he wants
to and unfortunately for k this is
exactly what glasses guy does kay now
has until after school to pay this bully
or else after school kay stops by the
bathroom as he tries to calm himself
down unless he does something he will
get beaten to a bloody pulp by the
school's most terrifying bully but then
his luck strikes again as he remembers
he brought his gants high-tech suit back
with him he puts a suit on getting ready
to meet the bully at the bully meeting k
stands quietly as the bullies beat up
another man who owes them money hoping
that if he stays silent for long enough
then he might just escape with his life
but this bully isn't having any of that
and he beats k to the ground beating him
so bad that he starts to go numb but his
horny brain just won't quit and then he
begins to have raunchy thoughts about
red haired gold disgusted beyond belief
the bully picks up k and is ready to
clobber him until k thanks to his
raunchy thoughts activates his suits
powers and knocks this bully out what k
doesn't know is that his life will now
be on the line yet again in less than a
week okay this was the best case
scenario and frankly kaye walked the
line here a little bit if he had killed
this bully then this would have only
caused further problems for him down the
line think about it the charges for
murder and manslaughter are indictable
offenses which can only be heard by the
district court or the supreme court and
can result in capital punishment by
hanging and even if k didn't get the
death penalty through this an
investigation into this murder would
likely lead back to the suit that kaye
used to murder that bully which would
have inevitably led back to the
discovery of gantz which if the country
found out about his existence would have
led to kay's death by ghance because if
we remember the rules set by ghance at
the beginning stated that if anyone
finds out about gantz this would be
punishable by death so kay needs to
watch how he handles the public when he
has his suit on
hey so 80 are you not subscribed so go
subscribe now see ya
elsewhere we see a tough biker dude
red-haired guy who's playing house with
his baby mama and son as he goes off to
buy some cigarettes and milk for his kid
not realizing that he's about to die
within a few days back at k's house kay
returns to find red-haired girl waiting
outside and who has a strange request
turns out she's homeless and needs a
place to stay this terrifies kate as to
the possibilities that are about to
happen at least according to his horny
teenage imagination later that night k
and red-haired girl lay in bed as k
tries to be cheeky and kappa feel but
then all of a sudden is met with
red-haired girl's sad story explaining
to him how she came to be in ghats due
to her attempted suicide and is simply
too distraught to be in the mood for
anything later in the morning kato and
his little brother sit in punishment at
their aunt's house this aunt likes to
beat children and kato has had enough of
her [ __ ] as he threatens her telling her
to stop hurting his little brother kato
needs money to take his brother away
from this child abusing aunt before it's
too late the next day k hits the
supermarket with red-haired girl but
he's strapped for cash until he meets
grandma the very same grandma who he met
on the subway moments before he died kay
then rushes home with red-haired girl
and asks her to put on her gantt suit as
he thinks that this is a sign that he'll
get a call from gantz very soon kay
needs to learn how this suit works
before he is sent back in to risk his
life for gance alright it's a little bit
nuts that k hasn't figured out how his
suit works by now who knows when gantz
will call them back in he needs to get
acquainted with his biosuit asap if i
was him i would have coordinated with
the other members in my team and would
have tried to set up training days where
we would all come together have a good
kumbaya and figure out how the suit
works and its mechanics together i would
have also worked together with kato to
take advantage of this redhead better
for the next game hear me out now it's
obvious that at this point that red herd
girl isn't attracted to me but is
attracted to kato by communicating with
kato that red haired girl just loves him
we can manipulate the red herd girl and
make her think that she has a shot with
kato this way her and him would get real
close together then by the time we have
the next gance game we could use her to
do our bidding and or tasks for us while
risking her life over ours red haired
girl struggles to put on the gantt suit
and she asks k how to use it but kaye is
scared to tell her the naughty truth so
he says that they'll have to find out
for themselves before heading to school
meanwhile judgment day has arrived and
the very same grandma from before i hate
that woman takes her kid on a day trip
not realizing that today is the day that
both of them will die at school kato
saves this kid from getting bullied as
the bullies themselves get pissed off
and plan to beat kato up after school
with this bully planning to violate him
if you know what i mean but thanks to
one dude informing kato about these
bully's horrifying plan kato then takes
matters into his own hands and goes into
the bathroom himself later on and
absolutely destroys this guy clobbering
his face in with no remorse or regard
for human life this isn't the good boy
kato that we know and gods has made him
a changed man and it's this level of
heartlessness that kato will need to use
in gantz soon elsewhere these two girls
check out this guy mr stud who's a
famous model who now has a stalker as he
notices this girl following him he then
asks these two heart flustered girls if
he can borrow their bikes the girls
agree as mr stud takes off in haste not
realizing that this bike by tonight will
cost him everything i'm sorry but if
you're a famous handsome stud like me
and i know everyone agrees that mr stud
himself should have already been
prepared to combat his stalker even if
she is a tiny little girl it's anime
people if she's small and tiny she's
very powerful you know what i mean i'd
personally recommend my favorite the
saber red pepper spray keychain small
compact and very cute but also discreet
and speaking of red peppers what kato
faced was actually very unsurprising as
bullying in japan is actually a very
very big problem with a record number of
incidents in a single year as high as
414
378 cases from elementary right through
senior year high schools and this like
the country itself has been linked
toward issues regarding conformity
meaning if you're taller than average or
prettier or look different then you
could be a target hat's off to cotto but
maybe wear a mask next time just so you
don't get caught and hey remember we
didn't start this fight so we're in the
right sort of the night of everyone's
death has arrived as redhead biker guy
gets ready to go out and buy milk not
realizing that tonight is his last night
alive he heads out and stops by his
gang's chill-out spot as they suddenly
get jumped by a rival gang the horror
show has just begun the rival gang draws
first blood as red-haired guy fights for
his life beating dudes up left and right
as his life depends on it because it
does at the same time on this bridge the
grandma and grandson get stuck at the
back of a traffic jam on the highway and
even crosses paths with motorcycle guy
who's stuck right next to them and the
universe prepares for what's about to
happen suddenly a truck in the distance
speeds up with this driver fast asleep
at the wheel as the truck simultaneously
gains momentum and heads straight for
granny and mr stud just as red-haired
guy gets stabbed in the stomach and
falls as his consciousness withers out
of existence the truck then slams into
mr stud grandma and her grandson killing
all of them with gantz laying claim to
the fallen victims of this night as
everyone dead or alive from before gets
teleported back into gans according to
the cdc an estimated 1 in 25 adult
drivers have reported falling asleep at
the wheel in the past 30 days with
drowsy driving being responsible for
over 91 000 crashes resulting in 50 000
injuries and nearly 800 deaths according
to the national highway traffic safety
administration that's a lot of players
for gans to use now realistically the
person with the best chances of
surviving was this kid children on
average have chubbier bodies and a
higher proportion of body water so they
are more robust to injury they're also
likely better able to cope in dangerous
situations as they would be on average
more relaxed than adults who will be
quicker to understand when their lives
are at risk but also he was the only one
who could have possibly made it out in
time from before the truck hit grandma
is likely way too dang old and slow to
react at the speeds necessary to stand a
chance unless she has a lot of titanium
plates in her old bones then maybe
she'll survive anyways mr stud was
trapped on the bike thanks to that
clingy stalker of his just so y'all know
it's not like the movies the oil tanker
truck itself actually wouldn't have
necessarily exploded unless it was
nearly empty as if we assumed there was
gasoline in it would have needed oxygen
to burn and a lot of it to cause an
explosion but of course kids are stupid
everyone appears in the room but this
time with some new members as
right-haired guy shows up with his
fallen gang along with grandma and her
grandson and mr stud all the new players
mirror how k and kato reacted when they
first came here freaking out and
demanding answers kato tries to tell all
of them the gist of the situation but no
one believes him especially the biker
gang not knowing that they'll soon all
be at risk of dying a horrible death if
they don't get it together quick just
then gance turns on and gives the group
the rundown of their next alien target
this suzuki alien who looks harmless and
barely a threat and the biker gang
laughs it off thinking this to be a
prank of sorts underestimating their
target and that was their biggest
mistake suddenly gantz releases the
weaponry as this excites the biker gang
the group then haphazardly begins
getting ready just as k realizes that he
left his suit at home he starts to freak
out knowing what we already know that
he's dead meat without it red-haired guy
starts to believe what katu is saying as
he suits up as he tries to make the
others listen but k in the background
tries to be sneaky and grabs the other
gang member suit to wear you might as
well if they're not interested but then
kato finds out that kay doesn't have his
suit and then pleads for one of the gang
members to lend k their suit but none of
them agree and even creepy-haired kid
says that all suits are made for the
individual assigned wearer meaning
wearing any suit k wears will not work
unless it's his own kaye's face turns
white as one of the gang members tries
to shoot creepy-haired kid in the head
but fails just as he returns the favor
but this time killing one of the biker
guys spilling his blood everywhere
creepy-haired kid has had enough
politeness for one day and mentions that
in gantz everybody is against everybody
claiming that everyone in here is just a
walking corpse with an expiration date
especially k and just then they are
teleported by gants to the next game
okay so i acknowledge this is not good
but our odds of surviving have just gone
up exponentially we've gotten new
members who are clueless as to what's
going on which is great we can use that
to our advantage i would have preyed on
the vulnerable people in this group
starting with grandma and her kid we may
as well use the stupid motorcycle gang
excluding red-haired guy he's pretty
cool this would have been the perfect
opportunity to lie to them about the
purposes of the game and the need for a
gans suit and this way during the game i
could have separated the new members and
used them as bait to lure the aliens
towards us we all noticed that the green
alien was more vulnerable when he was
distracted before creepy guy shot him so
in this regard we could use this same
strategy to at least ensure that we are
not the first ones to die as we try to
catch the aliens one by one using the
new members as bait suddenly k appears
as he pops into existence right near the
terrifying suzuki robot and it's headed
right for him they have 57 minutes left
the alien goes past him and his surprise
doesn't attack him until he accidentally
captures its attention now coming for
him k runs for his sweet little horny
life as he finds the main group nearby
and the group lays eyes on this very
fast strong and menacing suzuki alien
who won't stop at anything until
everyone is dead the group stands frozen
as they don't know if this wimpy robot
is the only alien and we know how that
turned out last time this alien then
gets angry and uses its supersonic voice
blaster blowing back everyone and
causing the invisibility factor of
creepy hair kid's suit to turn off he
then tries to shoot the robot as it
hovers above him forcing creepy-haired
kid to make a run for it as he turns his
invisibility back on but this robot is
too damn smart for him and senses where
creepy-haired kid is until the worst
thing happens creepy-haired kid's
invisibility suit has just run out of
battery he's trapped the robot draws
nearer to him prepare to kill him as
creepy-haired kid then begs for everyone
else up on the bridge to save him but
red-haired guy then tells him that he
needs to repent for his sins for killing
his biker buddy earlier and if he does
that then he will save him but
creepy-haired kid refuses as he makes
one last move and attempts to punch the
alien just as his suit loses all of its
health creepy-haired kid then bakes for
his life one last time kanto has had
enough he jumps down there to save him
but the robot then screams at a
supersonic pitch blinding and deafening
him kato then distracts the alien and
grabs creepy-haired kid before he's
knocked down by the robot just as kato
pulls a last stand move and bear hugs
the robot squeezing the life out of him
literally as much as i hate this
creepy-haired kid him being vulnerable
means that he'd make the perfect bait
for any situation from now on and also
means that the most experienced member
of the game is done for which is good
news for us since we're the second most
experienced members in this game saving
him was necessary as these robots while
dangerous were not the most dangerous in
the game if we can predict that the gans
game will use the same rules every time
then it's safe to assume that these
suzuki aliens are not the toughest bad
guys that we have yet to face in this
round as we usually bump into them
towards the end of the game this means
that the toughest alien is still out
there which means we need all the help
we can get including having somebody
barely alive to use as a distraction i
would have done exactly what kato did
but not out of compassion or human
nature but out of calculating tenacity
because we need to be ruthless granny
and her grandson tag along with the
other people and they decide to go home
but then suddenly this guy's head
explodes causing everyone to start
running like their lives depend on it
kato now with a badly injured
creepy-haired kid wonder why they
haven't been transported back yet as
this guy is running out of time but then
realizes a fatal mistake if they haven't
been transported back that means they
haven't found all the aliens yet and to
add to the bad news creepy-haired kid
finally dies as his damaged body exhales
its last breath just then the motorbike
gang comes back scared shitless
informing the group of what just
happened that they can't leave the area
until they finished the game they also
realized that grandma and her kid aren't
here so they set out to find them and
the aliens leaving a suitless k
red-haired guy and this biker guy behind
but this biker guy has other plans as he
aims his lethal gun at both red-haired
guy and k demanding their weapons
meanwhile kanto and the group finds
grandma and her grandson but also find
on the locator more terrifying aliens
headed their way kato then tells the
grandma and her grandson to run as kato
grabs the robot squeezing the life out
of it as more aliens try and kill him
killing one alien and its inner chicken
before his suit gets fully drained he's
out of health defeated and weak kato
sits there waiting to die until red
haired chick starts blasting away some
aliens and they work together to defeat
the group they then realize that they
need to find the grandma and her
grandson and the rest of the group
before it's too late there were more
than enough people in this situation to
handle this alien if they managed their
responsibilities better this alien is
known as a suzuki alien which is a
bird-like organism that cannot survive
in our environment hence why they need
to live in a cybernetic suit in the form
of seiji tanaka for whatever reason this
means that despite their whole being
strong their whole was their one
weakness the gang could have split up
and distracted the aliens from the jump
and then surprised the alien by using a
four to five man team to combat it with
one ganz player arm barring the neck
resulting in the suzuki alien being
unable to move their neck effectively
limiting their neck's anatomical range
of motion and preventing them from
shooting their oral energy beam from
almost all directions then the
subsequent gans players could have
grabbed a hold of each of the alien's
limbs with another two members being the
ones to squeeze the alien's hole from
the back and front of the alien body
disabling its ability to fire its beams
from its mouth and arms and then being
able to compress the alien's body
without taking damage squeezing the hull
until the bird alien within dies coming
out like a bottle of squeezed toothpaste
elsewhere k and red-haired guy are led
by gunpoint by this biker guy until they
come across a signal showing the
location of some more aliens and he
shoves kate into the house to check it
out not realizing that this location may
be the location of all of their deaths
if they aren't careful back in grandma's
area she has the biggest problem of all
her grandson needs to pee and he takes
his suit off to take a leak suddenly
more terrifying robots show up and the
grandma quickly tells the kid to run but
as the grandson runs away he stops as he
hears his grandma's horrifying screams
causing him to go back and witness the
most savage sight it's grandma but she's
covered in blood he goes to hug her as
they embrace tenderly in their last
moments before being obliterated by the
aliens kato arrives late to the
bloodbath and he sees the grandmother
and her grandson's blood-covered corpses
they were too late back at kay's
location he stumbles upon a hallway and
he hears some noises rumbling behind the
door and just then all the doors open to
reveal even more horrifying aliens and
to add to more bad news a new alien
emerges from the back room the most
insane thing that k has ever laid his
eyes on this terrifying monster bird
alien
oh my gosh that thing is bigger than the
big prawn of new south wales but we
can't rely on the australians to help us
beat this bird when they couldn't even
beat the emu way back when useless no
offense australia but my bet is that
this bird's weak point will be like that
of those of the aliens from earlier this
alien seems to be a modified version of
the suzuki alien and what this does
makes me suspect that this alien's
reliance on external resources to
function normally may be the key to
defeating it especially if we deduce
that the apparatus flowing into its
mouth is its breathing apparatus much
like our encounter with the previous
robot aliens in theory we could try
gunning it towards the breathing
apparatus by shooting at it point-blank
range we need to try and disable the one
thing keeping it functioning within our
atmosphere b4 this bird tries to clear
the building because once it leaves then
it will be game over for us as it'll
have the upper hand when it takes flight
kate was already within grabbing
distance when he held up that bird at
point-blank range he simply had to blow
a hole through its breathing equipment
causing his demise in one fatal sweep
why didn't he do that with only a few
minutes on the clock kaye tries to
muster some courage but is met with a
shitstorm of a situation causing the
building to crash and k to get the hell
out of there but the horror show isn't
over yet as this alien blasts out the
door and grabs this blonde guy tearing
his head right apart suddenly grabbing
kane the process and flying him high
into the sky kay struggles to try to
break free but he's no match for this
feathered beast if he doesn't free
himself soon then they are all dead with
eight minutes left to go kay struggles
and struggles and finally frees himself
from this feathered beast but it comes
at the cost of falling straight to his
death in his last moments mid-free fall
kay busts out his blaster and blows a
hole in this alien a mile wide causing
him to kill the final opponent in this
death-defying game he survives the epic
fall and the death game itself finally
teleporting everyone back to gantz for
their scores and for their freedom but
they know what we know that this
horrifying game isn't over and it's only
a matter of time until their turn to
play comes again and if you like playing
with dirty japanese monsters as much as
i like playing with watches like comment
let us know what you liked and of course
didn't like it don't get to check out
the how to be playlist down below